Weltweit lückenlosen Internet-Zugang für
Alle! Mit “Starlink” will Elon Musk genau
das möglich machen! Bis 2027 sollen dafür
knapp 12.000 Kleinsatelliten um die Erde kreisen.
Doch schon die ersten 60 Test-Satelliten sorgten
jetzt für hitzige Debatten im Netz: Der Grund:
Die Satelliten waren als extrem helle Lichter
am Himmel zu sehen. Kritiker und Kritikerinnen
sehen dadurch die bodengestützte Astronomie
bedroht und befürchten zudem die endgültige
Vermüllung des Weltraums…Was ist an dieser
Kritik dran und was hat Elon Musk dazu alles
getwittert? Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier
gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. Herzlich willkommen!
Elon Musk, der Chef des US-Amerikanischen
Raumfahrtunternehmens SpaceX, will Internet
mit Höchstgeschwindigkeiten für Alle möglich
machen - und zwar bis zu ein GB/s pro Nutzer.
Immer wieder betont Musk, dass sein Plan unter
anderem darauf abzielt, „möglicherweise
Milliarden von ökonomisch benachteiligten
Menschen zu helfen“. Realisiert werden soll
das Projekt “Starlink” mit Hilfe von etwa
12.000 Kleinsatelliten, die in verschiedener
Höhe um die Erde kreisen. 2027 soll diese
Mega-Konstellation an Satelliten am Himmel
sein. Ende Mai waren die ersten 60 Satelliten
auf den Weg gebracht werden sollen. Doch die
Reaktionen fielen ganz anders aus als erwartet.
Denn schnell kursierten im Netz Videos von
den Satelliten, wie sie ihre Bahn über den
Nachthimmel zogen. Quasi wie an einer Schnur
aufgefädelt - einer nach dem anderen. Zum
Entsetzen Vieler waren sie dabei eben sehr
sehr deutlich am dunklen Himmel zu erkennen.
Der Grund dafür: Die Solarpanele der Starlink-Satelliten
reflektieren das Licht der Sonne auf die Erde.
Eine hitzige Debatte wurde daraufhin losgetreten
- zum größten Teil auf Twitter. Wie solle
man sich den Himmel vorstellen, wenn er demnächst
einmal von hunderten Satelliten beleuchtet
wird?! So twitterte bespielsweise der US-Astronom
Alex Parker: “Mit an die Dunkelheit angepassten
Augen und ohne Lichtverschmutzung kann man
rund 9000 Sterne am Nachthimmel sehen, verteilt
auf die gesamte Himmelssphäre. Wenn die 12
000 Starlink-Satelliten auch in ihren endgültigen
Umlaufbahnen sichtbar bleiben, dann…”
(Quelle: https://twitter.com/Alex_Parker/status/1132164975911268353)
Würde das vielleicht sogar im schlimmsten
Fall das Ende der bodengestützten Astronomie
bedeuten? Schließlich könnten die Starlink-Satelliten
Sterne und Galaxien überstrahlen oder gar
verdecken - so die besorgten Tweets. Doch
nicht nur das. Auch andere Geschehnisse am
Himmel könnten uns diesen Befürchtungen
zufolge durch die Lappen gehen. Beispielsweise
Supernova-Explosionen oder aber auch potentiell
gefährliche Asteroiden. Aber auch die “Internationale
Astronomische Union” hat sich eingeschaltet.
Die Fachleute zeigen sich “besorgt über
diese Satelliten-Konstellationen“. Wünschenswert
sei demnach “das Prinzip eines dunklen und
funkstillen Himmels“. Unter anderem auch
als „Ressource für die gesamte Menschheit
und zum Schutz nachtaktiver Tiere“. Die
Satelliten stellen demnach eine Bedrohung
dar - auch wenn die Absichten dahinter begrüßenswert
seien. Die Organisation fordert deswegen,
die Entwicklung eines Rechtsrahmens, “um
die Auswirkungen auf die wissenschaftliche
Erforschung so bald wie möglich zu verringern
oder zu beseitigen.” Elon Musk selbst äußerte
sich per Tweet zu diesem Thema. Doch dadurch
heizte er die Debatte noch weiter an. Denn
seiner Meinung nach seien Weltraumteleskope
DIE Zukunft der Astronomie: “ (..) Starlink
won’t be seen by anyone unless looking very
carefully & will have ~0% impact on advancements
in astronomy. We need to move telescopes to
orbit anyway.” (Quelle: https://twitter.com/elonmusk/status/1132897322457636864)
Außer Acht gelassen hat er dabei die Tatsache,
dass erst in der jüngsten Zeit einige gigantische
bodengestützte Teleskope gebaut wurden. Wie
beispielsweise das größte Radioteleskops
weltweit, das 2016 seinen Betrieb aufgenommen
hatte. Der Hauptspiegel des Observatoriums
FAST (Five hundred meter Aperture Spherical
Telescope) hat einen Durchmesser von unglaublichen
530 Metern. Die Chinesen wollen mit seiner
Hilfe bahnbrechende Entdeckungen machen; unter
anderem bei der Suche nach außerirdischem
Leben. Zudem seien seine Starlink-Satelliten
nur während der Dämmerung zu sehen, da sie
nachts - ebenso wie die Sterne - im Dunklen
seien. Diese Aussage von Musk ist allerdings
nicht ganz korrekt, denn die endgültige Umlaufbahn
einiger seiner Satelliten liegt in einer Höhe
von 550 Kilometern. Und dort scheint oft auch
die Sonne, wenn bei uns auf der Erde tiefste
Nacht ist. Widerspruch bekommt Musk von renommierten
Astronominnen und Astronomen - beispielsweise
von dem niederländischen Astrophysiker Cees
Bassa. Seinen Berechnungen zufolge werden
die Satelliten vor allem in den Sommernächten
IMMER zu sehen sein. Demnach würden alleine
schon die ersten 1500 Starlink-Satelliten
zu einer enormen Charakter-Veränderung des
Himmels führen. Andere Fachleute sehen das
Ganze nicht ganz so pessimistisch. Doch auch
Radio-Astronomen sehen Musks Vorhaben als
überaus kritisch. Denn bisher ist nicht wirklich
geklärt, ob die Funksignale auch deren sensiblen
Empfänger beeinträchtigen könnten. Ein
weiterer Kritikpunkt der vielen Skeptiker:
die zunehmende Vermüllung des Weltalls. Doch
Musk hat das alles so nicht auf sich sitzen
lassen und zog Ende Mai mit einem weiteren
Tweet nach: “Agreed, sent a note to Starlink
team last week specifically regarding albedo
reduction. (...)” (Quelle: https://twitter.com/elonmusk/status/1132908689860415488)
Demnach soll sich sein Team also darum kümmern,
den sogenannten “Albedo” zu reduzieren.
Also denjenigen Anteil des Lichts, den eine
Oberfläche absorbiert. Im Fall von Satelliten
ein hoher Wert, da sie viel Licht reflektieren,
um zu vermeiden, dass sich die Elektronik
an Bord zu sehr aufheizt. In einem weiteren
Tweet versprach er auch, bestimmte Frequenzbänder,
die eben für die Radioastronomie vorgesehen
sind, zu meiden. Auch in Sachen Weltraumschrott
habe SpaceX vorgesorgt. Denn die jetzt gestarteten
Satelliten werden laut einer Sprecherin nach
ihrer Lebensdauer von etwa fünf Jahren in
der Erdatmosphäre verglühen - und das fast
rückstandsfrei. Dennoch: Die Kritik an seinem
Vorhaben reißt nicht ab. Astronomin und Bloggerin
Noisy hat dazu eine mehr als deutlich Meinung:
“Hier kommt ein mächtiger, reicher, weißer
Dude, der großzügig den armen Nicht-Weißen
der Welt Internet bescheren wird, ohne Wert
darauf zu legen, sie dabei zu Partnern zu
machen oder auch nur zu fragen, was sie wirklich
brauchen”. Sieht der Himmel also in Zukunft
ganz anders aus als wir ihn kennen, weil aus
ihm ein einziger Satelliten-Himmel ist? Eine
Frage, die derzeit nicht ganz klar beantwortet
werden kann, da einige Parameter wie beispielsweise
die Ausrichtung der Solarzellen noch unbekannt
sind. Unklar ist bislang zudem, ob solch ein
Satelliten-Himmel tatsächlich ein Problem
für Hobby-Astronomen und Riesen-Teleskope
werden könnte. All das wird derzeit und auch
zukünftig wohl über unseren Köpfen erprobt.
Macht SpaceX Raumfahrt unmöglich? [Update]
(2019) Anklicken. Anschauen und Abonnieren
nämlich den Hammer kanal Raumzeit Vlog der
Zukunft. Bis dann, bleibt dran!